In the porn that we looked at last time.
Uh,
that was the poem Ad Pod Trim that Milton had addressed to his father.
Milton was attempting to,
as you remember,
to justify to his father his own interest in becoming a poet.
And so I'm going to ask you to turn back to ad trim.
Uh,
this is page 83 of the hues edition.
This is where Milton is accounting for himself and his choice of a poetic
career.
Now look at that.
This is page 83 and the second verse,
Paragraph Milton tells his father,
do not despise divine poetry.
The poets creation.
No,
actually it's in the Hughes.
It's do not despise divine poetry,
creation of the prophetic barred,
nothing better shows our heavenly origins are divine seed,
our human intellect,
those holy traces of Promethian fire and look a little further down in the same,
uh,
same paragraph.
Builtin continues his defensive,
what he calls the poet's task.
Poets are not only do the highest respect imaginable here on earth,
Milton's explaining to his dad a poets are rewarded as well in heaven.
And so Milton rights,
uh,
MS,
page 83 and when we returned to our native Olympus and in a classical piece in a
Latin poem like this by the nae aren't native Olympics,
he always obviously means the Christian heaven.
And when we returned to our native Olympics and the everlasting ages of
immutable Aternity are established,
we and he means we poets,
we will walk crowned with gold through the temples of the sky.
And with the SA Harps soft accompaniment,
we shall sing sweet songs to which the stars shall echo in the vault of heaven
from pole to pole.
Unbelievable.
Now,
Milton's being serious here and we were given every rhetorical queue possible
that Milton is being serious.
Then he's just conjured one of the most extraordinary rewards conceivable for a
poet.
Forget,
forget the poultry crown of Laurel place to top the heads of great writers in
the classical tradition.
What good is that going to do?
Your Milton is actually talking about heaven here and,
and uh,
and the,
their reward for the poets sacrifice here on earth is not simply eternal fame.
That,
that,
that had long been a,
a privileged image.
It is a,
it's a priority status in the great hereafter.
This is Milton's argument and if heaven is going to be segregated as Milton
seems to believe,
that would be into hierarchies and classes,
then surely poets would enjoy the privileges of the highest class of all as they
walk crowned with gold through the temples of the skies and with the harps soft
accompaniment,
sing sweet songs.
Now we're,
we have to ask where it could Milton have come by by such an idea as this,
this image of a special reward in heaven for certain types of behavior does of
course have some sort of scriptural basis,
but there's certainly nothing in the Bible to suggest that it's poets who are
issued the crowns of gold and especially a prominent place as they,
as they enter the pearly gates,
as as so often,
and this is something that we'll get very used to.
He used to hear Milton's incorporating it into his own text,
a biblical text on a subject almost entirely different from the one of his own
idiosyncratic poem.
And so often Milton has no choice but to,
to wrench and to violate the biblical text,
to force it,
to Wa,
to force it to say to what he wants to say what he wants it to say,
or to force it to say what he needs it to say.
Now,
this illusion here,
uh,
in this averse epistle and the versa pistol to his father is a passage from the
book of revelation,
Milton's alluding to the,
to what he took to be the divinely inspired prophecy of,
of Saint John The divine that ends the New Testament.
And so this is a,
and I put this on the handout,
this is from chapter 14 of the book of revelation.
I heard the voice of Harper's herping with their harps,
and they sung as it were,
a new song before the throne.
And no man could learn that song.
I've skipped a little bit,
but the hundred and 40 and 40,000 which were redeemed from the earth,
these are they which were not defiled with women for they are virgins.
So according to John,
the author of the,
the presumed author of revelation,
it's not poets.
Um,
who get to when their songs to the soft voice strings.
It's not poets who are crowned with gold as they,
as they learn the song no other men could learn.
These are honors,
reserved exclusively for virgin honors,
reserved only for those who do not defile themselves with the sins of the flesh
and S.
And so it's as if something in the,
in the figurative,
figurative world of Milton's poem to his father has,
has,
I don't know,
how do we put it has gone awry.
And unless we're willing to concede,
and we're probably not that all poets are necessarily male virgins,
uh,
you,
you can pretty much safely say that there's a,
there's a significant disjunction here between Milton's own text and the
passage,
the text in the book of revelation that he's alluding to.
It's,
and this is an opportunity for us as this is what we get paid.
This is what I get paid to do and what you're getting credit for learning to do.
It's just this type of signifying gap that compels us,
us as literary critics to dive in and to begin to explore.
So the,
the,
the first question is how do we understand the slippage here from virgin,
the biblical virgin to the miltonic poet and,
and,
and more generally,
what could poetry possibly have to do with virginity.
You remember from the,
I hope you remember from the sixth allergy that's sex to allege gea that we read
a few classes ago that Milton had told his friend,
Charles,
do you dotty that an aspiring epic poet should,
uh,
one should only drink waters to,
should refrain from eating meat and three should keep his body chaste and the
figure of the poetic rewards for chastity continues to surface,
uh,
throughout Milton's early Milton's early works,
Eh,
you,
you remember the letter to a friend that we looked at lap for the last time.
Milton seemed to have decided against marriage as he was wedding,
making the decision to wet himself to his poetry instead.
And,
and in a,
in,
in the group of poems that were assigned for section last week,
even though of course you didn't have section last week.
Um,
you,
you saw Milton eluding to justice passage,
although you might not have known it alluding to just this passage in revelation
14 whenever he would speak of the music of the spheres.
So in the,
in Atala Music and in the poem Arkadis Milton turns to to what he considered to
be the greatest song of all the music of the heavenly spheres.
And he indicated that there are only a few just men,
just um,
honorable men who can't even hear those celestial notes.
And it would appear that Milton suggesting that it's chastity that actually
established it something like a precondition for hearing and learning,
that inspired song that's actually sung before the throne,
the throne of God in revelation.
So true poetry for Milton,
true prophetic poetry that the kind of song that can actually vie with the most
perfect music of the spheres is only accessible and presumably only producible
by the virgin.
Now the first wait,
we can't neglect the first order question here,
which has at least for me,
did Milton really believed this?
Could Milton actually have believed that poetic success was in some way
contingent on what it is that you do or what it is you don't do with,
with your body.
And obviously we can't,
we don't have him here.
And who knows the degree of honesty that he would bring to our question if he
were here.
We can never know the answer to the question of,
uh,
of Milton's Milton's actual beliefs.
But we know how Milton wanted to represent those youthful beliefs,
which is exactly what he does in the,
in the pros treatise with the wonderful title and apology for smack.
Tim Lewis
don't be put off by the name smack.
Tim Lewis is a made up name.
Uh,
it's an a and Milton didn't make it up.
it's an acronym.
He takes the initials of five Presbyterian ministers and combines them in such a
way that it forms the name.
It almost sounds obscene.
Smack Tim Lewis.
Um,
so the apology for smacked him newest is written in 42.
What's it about eight years after Columbus.
And we haven't,
I know we haven't gotten to comments yet,
but I'm trying to put this into context.
And in this pamphlet,
this pros treatise,
Milton is looking back at this exuberant affection for the very idea of chastity
that he had held in his youth.
And you'll,
and you'll note,
and there's no reason that you need to read more of this,
but the,
the Hughes edition only includes a portion,
a small portion of the actual pamphlet.
So this treatise is a whole,
is Milton's diff defense of these six Presbyterian ministers who wrote a
treatise criticizing the authoritarian structure of the,
of the English church.
Milton was also a,
at this time,
becoming an opponent of the Anglican Church government.
And he was writing and publishing a cha attacks on the church alongside this,
uh,
the smack new ones.
This smacked him newest group.
Now the,
the,
the Church of England establishment always countered these,
uh,
these puritan treatises and attack of their position.
And in a particularly vicious critique of so-called smack Tim Lewis and
anonymous Anglican opponent attack,
not only these six Presbyterian ministers,
but attacked Milton as well.
And I think this might be the first time that John Milton has actually,
um,
attacked or brought to the attention of the English people,
in print.
So we have this anonymous attacker who dismissed Milton's earlier political
treatises,
especially the apology or a pest.
All the reason of church government and other early works.
Um,
he dismisses Milton by waving that an unscrupulous ad hominem attack.
He argued that,
that this,
this John Milton fellow simply couldn't be heated on matters of the church are
on matters of the state because Milton himself had absolutely more no moral
authority.
Um,
he,
he accused Milton of frequenting play houses and also a frequenting bordellos
and we ask ourselves honest,
honest to Pete,
uh,
Milton hour,
John Milton frequent a Bordello I and I hope you have no choice.
You have to agree with me here.
Um,
perhaps he might have bordello oriented thoughts,
but there is no way in hell that this unspeakably self-controlled young man
would actually find himself in a,
in,
in a whorehouse.
Um,
the accusation is absurd and Milton knew it was absurd,
but he loves the attack.
Nonetheless.
You can tell he does because it gives him this extraordinarily happy opportunity
of defending himself and justifying himself,
which is what he does with the,
with this special vigor.
This is on page 695 of the hues in the apology.
Milton explains the preposterous of the idea that he has ever visited a
prostitute.
In fact,
he claims he was so far from such debauchery that he had that he had devoted his
in his entire early life to the ideal of virginity.
Now Milton knows that this might sound a little [inaudible] sound a little silly
coming from a young man and he acknowledges here finally that the ideal of
virginity is an ideal for which women are typically praised.
And,
uh,
of course this,
this goes without saying and patriarchal societies.
Um,
there tends to be an inordinate degree of interest,
uh,
placed on the virginity of young women.
It's,
it's as if the co and this just,
it matters more for women than for men.
It's as if the commodity of the bride is deemed truly valuable only if it can be
guaranteed,
pure and untouched.
Milton recognizes that way of thinking as a double standard and he isn't
satisfied with the double standards.
So he comes up with a,
with a,
with a vulgar double standard of his own.
This is the argument,
since men are clear,
clearly what he calls the perfector sex,
the perfect or sex,
surely they should be held to even higher standards of bodily purity even than
women.
So given the elevated status of,
of,
of men,
it's all the more important that men should remain pure and chaste.
And so we have Milton arguing,
this is on the top of page six 95 and I'm quoting here,
if on chastity and a woman whom Saint Paul terms the glory of Man,
be such a scandal in dishonor,
then certainly in a man who was both the image and glory of God,
it must,
they'll commonly not so thought be much more indie,
flowering and dishonorable in that he sins both against his own body,
which is the perfect or sex and his own glory,
which is in the woman.
And that which is worse against the image and glory of God,
which is in himself.
Nor did I slumber over that place.
And he's referring to that text in the Bible that we've just looked at.
Nor did I slumber over that place,
expressing such high rewards of ever accompanying the lamb with those celestial
songs to others in apprehensible,
but not those who were not defiled with women.
Now,
the place in the Bible over which Milton couldn't slumber was obviously this
revelation 14,
and it has to be said that Milton lost all the young Milton lost a lot of sleep
over this,
over this passage.
Uh,
Milton we know was seriously looking,
are we,
we have to assume was seriously looking forward to high rewards in heaven as a
virgin.
And as a poet,
he would hear and sing those songs.
Uh,
two others in apprehensible,
the celestial music.
And we can see the Milton astutely exploits.
It's brilliant.
The sexist implications of Saint John's treatment of virginity for both,
uh,
John of the book of revelation.
And for John Milton,
it's the superior male of the species that's been singled out for the glorious
practice of sexual abstinence.
Now this,
uh,
this,
this passage that we're looking at the passage from the apology as it has been
written.
Well after all of the poems that we're reading for today and Milton's writing
here from a,
from a slightly different,
we can think of it as a more mature perspective.
So in 1642,
you see Milton softening a bit in part because he's interested in getting
married and in fact he's married within a month of the actual publication of
this,
of this treatise.
This is why he tells us the parents,
theoretically,
marriage must not be called a defilement.
He's,
he's,
you know,
he's beginning to change his mind,
but at this,
but at the time period that we are examining,
uh,
the,
the period of Comis,
the early 1630s,
Milton seems very much interested in remaining virginal forever,
avoiding even the sanctioned loss of virginity,
which is the state of marriage.
Milton's,
Milton's college nickname as he,
as he tells us in the pro allusion six,
this is a,
a college exercise.
Milton's college nickname was the lady.
Now it's true that Milton skin,
and this is,
he tell,
he tells us this innumerable times,
and it's a,
it's vouched by others.
His skin was very fair.
Auntie to an unusual degree,
wore his hair quite long.
And he must have had,
it is conjecture to rather lady like appearance as a young man.
But I,
but I suspect,
I suspect that it was primarily Milton's intense interest in his college years
in his own virginity that led our young poets classmate at Christ's College,
Cambridge,
to call him the Lady of Christ's.
This is,
it's,
it's too easy.
And you know,
you,
you know where I'm going with this.
It's too easy,
but it's also,
this is why I can't help myself.
It's too delicious,
uh,
to take this little biographical fact of Milton's college nickname and use it in
some way as a tool for reading a mask.
The,
that this is the brief theatrical piece that Milton Rights in 1634 in which he
publishes in 1637 the heroine of the mask,
as you know,
it doesn't seem to have a Christian name.
Ah,
she's not Brittany or,
or Lindsay.
We're,
we're,
we're only,
we're only asked to think of her as the lady by her title and while it would be
ridiculous for us to read the entire mask as the poets own completely unfettered
autobiographical fantasy,
there is clearly,
and this is undeniable,
a miltonic set of interests and the miltonic set of anxieties,
charging and,
and fueling this work.
Okay.
The first,
we need to establish a few things about the occasion for this piece and about
the genre.
The literary genre of the mask in general,
Milton's mask was the product of a commission and as it's full title suggests a
mask presented at Ludlow castle.
It was commissioned to be performed at a specific locale.
Obviously Ludlow Castle,
which is in the west of England,
still there,
um,
near whales on the border of England and Wales.
And this was pre,
this piece was performed only once.
I'm on the religious holiday of,
of,
of Mikel Ms. Knight.
Now the theatrical form of the mask differs in a,
in a number of ways from the more familiar dramatic form of the play with which
we're all obviously much more
comfortable with it.
In the first place.
Uh,
a mask is nearly always occasional.
It's nearly always commissioned by the king to be performed at court before a
private audience of select nobility or it's commissioned as in the case of this
mask,
it's commissioned by an aristocratic family to be performed at the aristocratic
families estate to honor or to celebrate a specific occasion.
And so in the case of,
of,
of a mass here,
it's the,
it's the Lord John Edgerton,
the Earl of Bridgewater,
who commissioned Milton to write a piece honoring his own inauguration as the,
in his new role as the Lord President of oils.
So Milton wrote this mask with the specific cast in a specific audience in mind.
He wrote it to be performed by a Bridgewater's three children,
the lady Alice,
who obviously played bill lading and,
and Bridgewater's two sons there,
John and Thomas,
and they play the elder brother and the second brother respectively.
Alice is a,
is is 15 years old at the time.
Not An entirely unreasonable age for an actress or an amateur actress playing
the,
the maiden Lee,
but strong headed lady of Milton's masks,
Milton's mask.
But her brothers were,
and this is a little silly,
or her brothers were 11 and nine.
I'm unusually young actors.
We might think to be engaged in such high flying philosophical debates as these
two characters find themselves in whatever awkwardness of casting,
uh,
we have in this original performance.
Um,
W W W we'll cast that aside and,
and uh,
we have no choice but to understand that Milton's mask is serious business,
that the music,
that their whole production is one of the utmost seriousness.
The music for the mask,
which still exists.
Um,
at least the melody still exists was written by Henry laws,
the most important musician,
uh,
working in England.
He had just come from writing the music for a number of masks by the celebrated
playwright and mask writer Ben Johnson.
And it seems that laws himself actually played the role of the attendant spirit
that beneficence slightly a frightening figure who hovers over the entire
landscape of the mask.
Now,
it's been conjecture.
This is for a hundred or 150 years now that the actor playing comis in this
first and only performance in the 17th century was none other than our John
Milton himself and I,
and I'm quite sure that there are no historical grounds whatsoever for this
conjunction conjecture other than our perfectly perverse desire to imagine the
young self described Virginal Milton uttering.
Though the wanton and absolutely beautifully lascivious speeches of the magician
and of course would be molester comas and who could deny the satisfaction of
hearing our buttoned up young Milton,
I'm speaking one of comas is a magnificently sly and suggestive lines such as
with all that false innocence what half night to do with sleep.
He asks,
Comas asks,
uh,
the lady and as excited as a rouses we might find ourselves,
um,
by the,
by this imagining of Milton actually playing comas,
um,
of course is his performance in that role cannot be asserted in any way
definitively.
Um,
now as I mentioned,
the title of this piece was originally a mask presented at Ludlow castle and it
seems actually to have been known by the reading public,
uh,
by this title for a good hundred years or so.
But at some point in the 18th century,
the mask seemed informally to acquire an alternative title comas.
And it's as Comis that all readers since have have almost always referred to the
mask.
And this of course is a mistake.
It's a misnomer,
but the historical transmutation of,
of Milton's title,
um,
and we have to take as instructive and,
and so I want to propose that the literary traditions,
essentially a,
the literary traditions renaming of this piece from a mask to comas is more than
just a slip.
We're more than just a random shift of terms or have names on the,
on the face of things to call this mask.
Comas is absurd.
Comments is obviously the villain.
And for those of you who've read,
for those of you who've read paradise lost,
you'll notice that the characterization of comas prepares Milton and a lot of
important ways for his much later characterization of the character,
Satan,
comas and Satan,
or both seductive.
They're both rhetorically gifted temp doors and they actually share a lot of
rhetorical figures and moral concerns in common.
At times when we read paradise lost,
it seems almost as if Satan,
we're quoting or alluding to Comis,
but it's of course the lady who's the heroine of this,
of this piece.
And if we were to ask,
if we were asked to refer to the mask by the name of one of its characters,
I think we'd feel obliged to call it the lady or maybe the trials and
tribulations of the lady or the ultimate triumph of the lady,
something like that.
And we would name the mask after the lady.
It's she who represents the moral and doctrinal message that the mask itself
espouses.
The,
the lady is at the dogmatic heart of this relentless,
relentlessly didactic work of literature.
What did I just say?
I actually had,
um,
my,
I have,
I'm having terrible back pains right now.
I,
I I slept really badly last night.
What health night to do with sleep.
I assure you I wasn't enjoying myself.
Um,
so I,
I'm not sure exactly what I just said.
Did I say,
did I say that the lady is at the dogmatic heart of this relentlessly didactic
work of literature?
Is it possible to say that the lady successfully,
does that make any sense?
Is it possible to say that she successfully conveys a moral program that we can
any way identify as the official doctrine of the mask or has my,
uh,
my,
my state of sleeplessness and my,
and my aches and pains,
I'm disturbed my critical faculties that the casual renaming of the mask,
which happened well after Milton's death suggest that readers have been perhaps
less persuaded by the moral vision relayed by the lady and that they've been
perhaps overly persuaded by the subtle temptations of,
of comas and I,
and,
and this confusion I think has everything to do with the fact that this is no
ordinary moral that we have in this work of literature.
The focus of the mask is the loaded,
you'll grant me this and the always awkward subject of chastity and the,
and the actual morality of the kind of chance to do that the lady believes in,
uh,
I think raises a lot of questions about the clarity of the distinction being
formed here between,
between good and evil.
Okay.
So I'm partially going to retract what I had said about the lady's place at the
very heart of this work.
We're,
we're,
we're retreat.
Okay.
Look at line.
Uh,
okay.
Line two oh five.
Oh actually this is,
I'm thinking of page.
Yeah.
Page 95 in the Hughes were retreated,
were treated to the ladies singular investment in the integrity of her body and
her first speech.
Of course,
the ladies alone.
Why is she alone?
Because her brothers have naturally done with any brother would do.
I'm accompanying a sister and a dangerous forest at night.
They have abandoned her to pick berries or any such cooling fruit as the kind
hospitable woods provide,
uh,
Dr. Samuel Johnson,
the great,
the greatest of all 18th century critics is absolutely flabbergasted that Milton
would have these brothers do something so stupid.
It's so dark in the woods and the woods all alone that the lady can see nothing.
But nonetheless she can hear the riot and ill managed merriment of coma.
Stan is riot as Clu crew.
And I'm going to ask you to think of all of the images here.
The figurations of,
of listening and hearing in the mask.
The,
the,
the lady is overwhelmed
not by what she can't see,
but by what she can hear.
This is a page 95 this is line two oh five this,
this strange experience of hearing,
but not seeing a thousand fantasies begin to throng into my memory of calling
shapes and beckoning shadows,
Dyer and Arie tongues,
that syllable men's names on sams and shores and desert wildernesses.
Now I submit that the lady would appear to be less in control of her fantasies.
Then she is of her rigorously disciplined behavior,
however,
unyielding her dedication to her virginity and we have to say that it's
unyielding.
The lady is incapable of disciplining utterly her imagination and the rudeness
and Swill insolence of Comas,
his band of evil pranksters are,
are almost matched.
Perhaps they're even bested by the uncontrollable shapes that throng into the,
into the ladies' memory.
It's almost as if the labor,
the lady is,
is in some way harboring her own demons and it's,
it's as if we have an instance here of what this is.
This is an idea that I got from the Milton lecture when I,
that that I took when I was a sophomore here I'm the professors suggested this,
is that this is an instance of what Freud would call the return of the repressed
as the lady labors to preserve her virginity.
She conjures a a menacing,
but nonetheless,
it's a sensual image of Arie tongues,
that syllable men's names.
Now being the lady,
she,
she pulls her socks up.
She quickly recovers from this brief lapse,
a momentary lapse and essential reverie,
and she addresses all of those virtues that she cherishes so highly look at line
two and 13 oh,
welcome pure.
I'd faith white handed hope they'll hovering angel girt with old golden wings
and thou unblemished form of chastity.
I see visibly and now believe that he the supreme good to whom all things ill
are,
but as slavish officer's a vengeance would send a glistering guardian if need
were to keep my life and honor on a sale.
This lady doesn't need the WHO,
where her brothers are.
She doesn't need their protection because the god,
because God prizes chastity above all things and would gladly send a glistering
guardian to keep her on her,
on her,
on a sailed.
Now this,
I think we w we,
we might agree that this is a,
a reasonable enough fantasy of a female in vulnerability,
but of course there is nothing.
There is nothing in our sad experience with,
with sexual menace that actually bears this,
the theory behind this fantasy out,
but,
but think of how the lady has expressed this sentiment.
Oh,
welcome.
Pure ride,
faith,
white handed,
hope and vow,
unblemished form of chastity,
faith,
hope and chastity,
hope and chastity.
Do we do we read this right?
You,
you,
you may,
you may recognize the illusion.
The illusion here is obviously to the,
to the passage in First Corinthians that you can find on your handout.
This is one of the most famous verses in the,
in the Christian Bible,
Saint Paul Enumerates,
what he,
what we now call the cardinal virtues and now abideth faith,
hope charity,
these three.
But the greatest of these is charity.
Now we're not of course surprised by polls list of the virtues,
charity or,
or what he seems to have been thinking of is the selflessness of Christian Love
is a virtue,
generous and capacious enough to encompass all of the others.
But faith,
hope and chastity.
And the greatest of these is chastity.
It.
It's as if it's as if in some way we're being invited to measure the lady's
speech against the scriptural texts that supplies it's rhetorical foundation.
And I think it's impossible not to see that when Milton substitutes the virtue
charity with the far more circumscribed,
however virtuous it is,
it's a,
the much more circumscribed ideal of chastity.
There's something at least a little peculiar going on.
The lady,
it could be said,
appears to overvalue her chastity and it's in the general overvaluation of
chastity that we can best see the ways in which this,
this text comas begins to burst loose of the Orthodox Christian morality that we
tend to associate with pious Christian literature like this,
especially,
um,
the,
the literature of the mask.
Now it's the elder brother in the mask who offers us.
And even more,
if you can imagine it even more magnified view of the virtue of virginity.
They'll,
the lady herself had argued that heaven would send a glistering guardian down to
defend her physical,
her bodily integrity or physical innocence.
But the elder brother goes further even than that.
And it's his theory of the rewards do virginity that really just slings this
mask far from the reach is even a of anything even resembling mainstream
Protestant orthodoxy or for that matter orthodoxy of any kind.
Uh,
this is the,
this is the elder brother,
uh,
line for 53 page 100 in the Hughes.
Okay.
Chatting with is his younger brother.
So dear to heaven is saintly chastity,
that when his soul is found sincerely,
so a thousand livery the angels lackey,
her driving far off each thing of sin and guilt and in clear dream and solemn
vision,
tell her of things that no gross ear can hear till off to converse with heavenly
habitants and,
and,
and Milton or the elder brother here is clearly thinking of revelation 14 which
is the w in which it's only the pure air of the virgin that can even begin to
hear the new song being sung before the throne of the God of God.
The elder brother is explaining that these angels will begin to cast to beam on
the outward shape,
the unpolluted temple of the mind,
and turns it by degrees to the soul's essence till all be made immortal.
Okay?
It was,
it was one thing for the lady to imagine,
you know,
a crazy as it was for the lady to imagine a rescue squad of angels to,
to zip two or eight at the first hint of a physical assault.
And it was okay for Saint John de suggested.
Virgins are granted the best perquisites in the,
in the,
in eternity.
But think of what the elder brother has just given us.
He staged a scenario far beyond the wildest theological conjectures.
So dear to heaven is saintly chastity,
okay?
That heaven doesn't even permit vergence to die.
The thousand delivery to angels begin to cast their special beam on the,
on the Virgin's outward shape.
That's her body,
the unpolluted temple,
but that houses her virginal mind.
And this angelic laser begin slowly the gradual process in some kind of
extraordinary science fiction sort of way of transforming the virgin human body
to the essence of the soul itself.
It's as if this celestial laser beam were designed so as to actually shift the
atomic structure of the pure corporeal frame of the virgin his body.
Until that body is so rarefied,
so pure,
and ethereal,
that it's nothing but soul.
Okay?
She's been,
she's been,
she's been transmogrified from body to soul.
She's safe,
okay?
Mountain.
I'll never mind that.
That,
that our own experience with virgins has failed to afford us.
Such a spectacle of bodily transformation.
The elder brother is this theory without any consideration,
obviously,
whatsoever of earthly reality.
Uh,
and,
and we're shocked by,
I don't know how else to put it.
It's there because this is a theological conjecture,
I think were shocked by what is almost the heretical daring of what this brother
has just said.
Um,
uh,
unfortunately your editor merit cues and in this respect,
he's like all editors of Milton,
um,
does his very best to tame the outrageousness of the elder brothers speech.
And he follows the old editorial wisdom that holds that Milton can't possibly,
uh,
mean what he's actually saying here.
Hughes tells us that Milton's thinking of Plato and that the elder brother is
referring to the platonic theory that the,
that the noble spirit is released from the body after death.
But,
and this will be our mantra,
I hope for the rest of the semester,
we must not permit merit cues or any Milton editor to prevail in their efforts
at papering over the implications of a passage such as this.
Uh,
there's of course no mention whatsoever here of a soul being released from a
body after death,
that that would be an entirely orthodox image and we wouldn't be startled by its
presence.
But with the older brother is saying is that the virginal body is actually
transmogrified into soul.
The dirty business of physical death never has to take place at all.
That true virginity can provide the body with the release even from that
seemingly inexorable fact of death.
Well,
I mean,
we,
we have no,
we were,
were,
were prepared and no way to respond meaningfully to a speech such as that.
And,
and,
and clearly the second brother joins us in his bafflement.
Now look it,
the magnificent,
uh,
nonsequitor that he gives in response to the speech of his brothers.
The,
the,
the second brother says at line four 75,
how charming is divine philosophy?
Um,
the elder brother has obviously up the ante in the,
in the masks overvaluation of virginity.
And it's,
and it's possible that in this general drama of overvaluation that Milton's
working just because this whole thing is so extreme to distance himself from his
own youthful interest in the virtues of virginity.
That's one conjecture.
At least.
There seems to be something like a gentle parody,
maybe even a mocking tone that that fills the lines of the older brothers
ecstatic speech.
In any case,
the question of value and valuation,
it is an important one in comas and it's important in part because the rhetoric
of the mask is saturated in the economic,
the commercial,
the financial imagery that we were,
that we were looking at in the last lecture.
Milton,
we know,
we know this already gives pride of place to the images of money and trade that
he inherited from his father and so,
so we're not surprised that the central conflict in comas is,
is loaded with the rhetorical tokens of,
of commerce and exchange a look at line six 79 of the poem.
This is page 106 in the Hughes Comas is marshaling a serious,
a series of serious and perfectly and genius.
Our arguments in his attempt to seduce the lady,
uh,
which is really simply an attempt ostensibly to get her to drink from the glass
of cordial Julep,
which she has steadfastly refused drink up though he tells her,
and this is line six 79,
why should you be so cruel to yourself and to those dainty limbs,
which nature lent for gentle usage and soft delicacy,
but you invert the covenants of her trust and harshly to nature's trust and
harshly deal like an ill borrower with that which you received on other terms.
So nature nature has lent you your dainty limbs for a purpose.
Comas tells her,
but you're inverting the covenant of Nature's trust,
refusing to use and to spend those gifts that nature has given you.
Um,
according to comas,
the lady is an ill borrower.
She,
she doesn't spend her bodily wealth and fulfill the terms of nature's loan.
And so for Comas,
the nature,
the,
uh,
the lady is hoarding the natural asset of her,
of her physical beauty.
Look,
look,
look down.
Further line seven 39.
Beauty is he combs continues.
Beauty is nature's coin must not be hoarded but must be current in currency and
the good,
there've consistent,
mutual and partake in bliss,
unsavory in the enjoyment of itself.
Um,
with this,
with this phrase mutual and partake in bliss,
we develop an overwhelming sense that always seems to be trying to get the lady
to do something more simply than drink.
A sip of the cordial Julep from his charm had cup.
The discussion is obviously on some way really about sex and it's the ladies
virginity of course that's at stake here.
And with his accusation of the misuse of borrowed funds,
we recognize the strange and I think in this context rather ill fitting subtext
behind commas is seduction.
Comas is adopting the language from that parable in Matthew Matthew 25 that had
proven so significant and I think so painful for the young Milton for comas.
Nature is just like the harsh master who had given each of his servants,
uh,
a portion of money.
And who expects those coins?
Who expects those talents to be put,
to use the ladies' talent has to be spent.
It has to be invested in order to fulfill the covenant of the trust between the
master and the servant.
But the lady is hoarding that natural gift just as that unprofitable servant had
had buried his talent and the earth.
Now the Levy,
um,
it's been,
it's been noted before.
It's never really able to respond to combs.
His accusation of her hoarding,
she discussions what she would like to say in response to comments,
but she doesn't then go on significantly to say it.
She says nothing after this encounter remaining silent or speechless for the
rest of the mask.
But Milton clearly finds,
I think something,
something threatening here.
And if comas can be seen to pose a genuine threat to the lady,
it could very well be the threat posed by the power of comas.
This particular particular kind of poetry.
Okay.
Um,
I should have put on the handout and I failed to do that.
Uh,
the name of a couple of works of,
of Milton criticism that are especially,
uh,
especially valuable with respect to what I'm about to argue and to which I'm
indebted.
One is the chapter on Comis in a book by John Guillory called Poetic Authority.
And the other is,
uh,
the entire book,
by Angus Fletcher
on Milton's Comus.
What is that book called?
Thank you,
David.
The transcendental mask is,
uh,
and,
and both Guillory and Angus Fletcher or examining the,
the relation of Milton to one of his,
the troubled relation to melt into one of his favorite poets.
Um,
it's,
it's surely not insignificant that Milton's comas contains more echos of
Shakespeare than anything else that Milton wrote.
And it's,
and it's surely not insignificant that the,
the,
the ladies first song is actually addressed to the Nymph Echo that the mask is
all about the act of hearing song and the,
and the ethics of proper listening.
Th th the ladies first line in the mask is in fact about the music that comas is
producing that sh that she hears this way.
The noise was if mine ear be true,
my best guide now,
if mine ear be true,
my best guide now comas and the lady are continually listening do each other's
songs and the,
and the lady's goal is in some way to develop a way of listening that isn't at
the same time overwhelming or,
or perhaps deafening now what the lady listens to a might well be overwhelming.
Indeed.
It's the,
it's the speeches of comas far more than those of any other character that are
with echos in illusion,
echos in illusions to the great plays of Shakespeare.
Shakespeare presents himself as something like a powerful temptation in,
in this mask.
We remember that Milton's anonymous attacker in 1642 had not only claimed that
Milton could be found skulking around the back alleys of London's brothels.
Uh,
Milton was also a denizen.
It was alleged in this attack.
He was a Dennison of London's playhouses and,
and you can't help but notice that Milton and the apology for smack Timnah was,
it doesn't even begin to respond to that accusation.
It's like the lady with the accusation of Hoarding Shakespeare in the theater
seem to represent a temptation greater even than promiscuous sex or perhaps akin
to sex.
It's as if Milton places the beautiful poetry of Shakespeare into the mouth of
this evil magician.
So as to dismiss all the more easily that the easy leg grow mode of poetry that
Shakespeare scenes from Milton to embody.
Now we've,
we've,
we've been churning for a couple of,
a couple of weeks now,
Milton's long standing project to purge his lips of secular interests and to
cleanse his literary consciousness of the tempting influence of secular literary
voices.
And one of those voices is obviously Shakespeare's.
And so it's an understandable ploy on Milton's part that,
that,
that he needs to vilify Shakespeare by identifying that great poet,
his older contemporary,
um,
with comas.
But the standoff between Milton and Shakespeare,
much like the standoff between comas and the lady,
uh,
is not as easily resolved as it might seem to be.
The,
the logic,
the beauty of,
of comas.
His rhetoric seems often to overpower the ladies own,
which is itself,
admittedly beautiful and powerful.
And,
and we see in the poem itself an anticipation of the struggle that results
eventually in the 18th century and the new title of the Mask Comas has
successfully eventually,
he truly edges the lady out as this center of the entire work.
And,
and in the play itself,
in the fiction of the play,
the comas,
his argument simply leaves the lady in silence.
And,
and more than just silence,
she's actually incapable of speak.
She's capable of it.
We'll only see partially capable of speaking,
but she's actually physically incapable of moving most awkwardly.
The lady is physically stuck to her seat.
She stuck to Amar.
It's,
it's,
this is remarkable.
She stuck to a marvel venom deceit smeared with gums of gluten as heat.
Think about that.
Or is Columbus explains,
this is line six 58 ne ladies sit.
If I bet wave this wand,
your nerves are all chained up in alabaster and you a statue or as Daphne was
root bound that flood Apollo.
Now this isn't the first time that we have,
um,
in,
in Milton the representation of the,
of the turning of a person to marble.
It's,
this is actually a recurrent figure in the early poems,
a figure of frozenness or of there.
Isn't it wonderful that there's a term for being turned to marble
memorialization?
Um,
and this memorialization appears in a lot of the,
of the early poems I'm thinking of on Shakespeare,
the poem,
the passion as well as Lola grow and Heal Pencil Rosso.
And there's a moment in a lot of these poems in which the speaker finds himself
in a motionless in mobile or to actually turn to stone and on Shakespeare,
it seemed to be the set,
this sector of
the specter,
how,
what a great slip though the Spector with the Septor,
this,
the specter of Shakespeare that elicited this set of terms and images,
the idea of being frozen or Amar memorialized,
thou does make us marble with too much conceiving.
Milton had told Shakespeare in that poem,
the lady in Milton's mask is placed in a similar predicament,
but by the Shakespearian power of coma,
she's rendered,
she's mentored motionless,
and she's finally unable to speak.
She's unable to speak except to hint at a doctrine of virginity that finally
she's in incapable of articulating.
But,
and this is where we have to end this,
uh,
this session the lady does by the end of the poem get up from her seat.
She's released from her paralysis and she proceeds happily with her brothers by
the end of the poem to honor their father in Wales.
And if we wish to continue this analogist and I analogy and I certainly do
between the poet Milton and the Virgin Lady,
we can see that this is a release that John Milton,
the poet has been waiting some time for.
And so it only stands to reason that we pay some attention and it will have to
do this next week to how this release actually works.
Um,
just briefly,
a supernatural figure.
The nymph,
it looks like Sabrina,
but it seems,
I think it's pronounced Sabrina the Nymph.
Sabrina rises from a stream and unglued,
unglued the lady from her seat.
Now the,
the,
the mysterious mechanics of Sabrina's magic are profoundly mysterious.
And so I'm going to ask you to look especially closely for the next class,
and I want you to reread comas for the next class to look especially closely at
the Sabrina episode.
And I also want you to look closely at the,
not at the lines that are noted on the syllabus.
These are lines that were added a couple of years after the performance of
comas.
These are lines added when Milton actually gets around to publishing the mask in
1637.
So this is,
this is my final thought here.
If Milton as a poet who had never really published anything significant,
thinks of himself as a virginal rider,
then there's an important way in which Milton loses his virginity with his
published version of coma since 1637.
So for next week,
uh,
no for Wednesday,
reread comas.